[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une visite éclair que le général
de Gaulle a fait en Hollande haute a
déjeuné de la famille royale le
Président et Madame De Gaulle ont passé
quelques heures au château de Wiston
Bosch en compagnie de la reine Juliana
du prince Bernard des trois princesses
Béatrix Irène et margritte et du
ministre des Affaires étrangères
monsieur Loon
cette visite dont on a remarqué la
cordialité a contribué à détendre
l'atmosphère diplomatique qui régnait
entre les deux pays depuis la rupture
des négociations de Bruxelles sur
l'entrée de l'Angleterre dans le marché
commun
[Musique]
l'industrie des matières plastiques
connaît en France un développement
saisissant l'implantation de tels usines
dans diverses régions françaises à
contribué à l'expansion industrielle
mais un développement industriel
constant à l'échelon national 50 000
usines et ateliers créés depuis 10 ans
ne se conçoit que dans un grand
mouvement de capitaux c'est ici que le
Crédit national joue un rôle essentiel
sorte de pompe aspirante et foulante de
capitaux il offre à l'économie une
source constante d'investissement donc
d'extension dans tous les domaines y
compris bien entendu celui de
l'industrie lourde
des réalisations remarquables traduisent
la vitalité de ce secteur l'utilisation
simultanée de trois fours à arc
électrique produisant une qualité
d'acier identique a récemment permis
d'obtenir en France une coulée record la
plus importante obtenue en Europe et qui
permet de mouler directement des cages
de laminoir de 240 tonnes
[Applaudissements]
les problèmes sociaux demeurent
préoccupants en France transporté par
360 véhicules divers 2000 ouvriers des
mines de fer de Lorraine ont participé à
la marche sur Paris cette démonstration
destinée à alerter l'opinion publique
aura constitué la manifestation la plus
spectaculaire de la grève des mineurs
qui étaient entré dans sa troisième
semaine
[Musique]
pour 24 heures les cheminots à leur tour
s'engagaient dans la grève et des
menaces d'arrêt de travail semblaient
peser sur tout le secteur nationalisé
au 17e jour de leur mouvement alors que
l'on croyait une issue proche les
mineurs des charbonnages se sont réunis
à Lens au nombre de 40 000 au cours d'un
grand meeting
cependant des consultations entreprises
à Paris auprès des responsables
syndicaux par le comité des sages
laissaient la porte ouverte au dialogue
et du même coup à la possibilité d'un
règlement de la crise
[Musique]
tout a commencé à mon arrivée à Paris il
y a 3 ans en raison des événements je
vais quitté le Vietnam mon pays natal
avec mon enfant j'étais seule je n'avais
pas d'argent je ne connaissais personne
à Paris j'avais seulement un numéro de
téléphone celui d'un organisateur de
concours de beauté il accepta de me voir
il me donne un rendez-vous dans un café
il décida de s'occuper de moi et un mois
plus tard le 31 décembre 1960 j'étais
élue Miss France c'était merveilleux
mais c'était trop beau c'était un rêve
je n'ai pas voulu signer le contraste
scandaleux de mon organisateur et bien
il m'a destitué sous prétexte que
j'avais triché sur mon âge et que
j'avais un enfant alors tout s'écroula
dans mon quartier j'étais l'objet des
conversations c'était affreux voilà mon
histoire
mais l'USO j'ai réagi devant le tribunal
civil de Versailles et langage une
action contre le comité Miss France
maître Blateau lassiste
une autre Miss France Brigitte barazzer
vient témoigner le tribunal a donné
raison à l'usager car elle a démontré
qu'en posant sa candidature elle avait
produit son passeport ou son âge et sa
situation de famille était portée
Brigitte barazzer aussi a une opinion
bien établie barazet vous étiez Miss
France 60 je crois quels sont vos
grillettes à vous contre les
organisateurs des concours de beauté
bien toute la légende des belles robes
de
quand on arrive à la salle de restaurant
on prend trois menus pour 4 pour faire
des économies et on ramasse les restes
exactement votre propos
était évidemment de défendre des
intérêts de ma cliente mais je voudrais
surtout par cette audience à tirer
l'attention des jeunes filles de France
sur la prudence qui convient lorsqu'elle
participent à des concours pour ce titre
de Miss
fillette fillette attention le chemin
qui mène à ces royauté éphémères et
semer de plus de chardons que de fleurs
de lys
[Musique]
avec ses nouveaux quartiers quadrillés à
l'américaine ou pointe de si de la
building Lima capitale du Pérou offre
dès la mort l'image même d'une de ces
cités à la mode du Nouveau Monde les
vestiges d'une antique construction de
l'Empire InCar réduit à un monticule de
terre n’influent pas sur cette première
impression que suscite cette capitale
vouée à la civilisation de l'automobile
Halima pourtant à l'inverse de Buenos
Aires le présent n'a pas entièrement
recouvert le passé il y a quatre siècles
François pizza fixa sur les bords
désertiques du remake la capitale de sa
conquête et il créa de toutes pièces une
ville à l'espagnol
mais ces quatre siècles n'ont pas suffi
à effacer l'amour des balcons Andalous
d'autant plus insolites cependant qu’il
contribue à masquer une lumière déjà
voilée huit mois durant par le
brouillard du Pacifique
à l'ombre du plus beau d'entre eux
dorment les souvenirs de la vie royauté
[Musique]
au long de la rue dédiée aux dernières
Incas c'est encore l'Espagne qu'évoquent
les oliviers 4 x 69 sous lesquels les
limoniennes dégustent le maïs et les
limoniens la chicha alcool extrait du
maïs
[Musique]
20 l'heure de l'indépendance l'humain a
dédié au libérateur du Pérou procès de
San Martin l'une des plus monumentales
de ces places comme elle en a dédié une
autre au héros national de la guerre du
Pacifique l'amiral grahao mais ici
encore le présent s'ajoute au passé et
le dimanche devant l'église on ne
s’éteindra pas de voir la menti
espagnole encadrée uniformément des
visages que le brassage des races a
rendus bien différents
[Musique]
plus que n'importe quel autre monument
les églises évoquent la splendeur du
passé lors légendaire des Incas hybrides
tous ces feux
au voyageur d'aujourd'hui Lima offre de
singulier contraste la tentation des
immeubles modernes a fait surgir des
architectures rectilignes à côté
d'architecture ancienne et c'est tout à
la fois l'avenir le présent et le passé
qui se mêle
seul le vieux Lima résiste encore à la
surcharge des siècles encore qu'il soit
envahi par les automobiles
[Musique]
de leur passé espagnol les limonier ont
gardé une passion intacte la corrida
il s'y révèle des spectateurs assidus
d'autant plus que le Pacifique vers
lequel toutes les grandes avenues
convergent n'offrent qu'une autre eau
froide aux jolies baigneuses de l'été
austral
[Musique]
d'attraction de tout l'arrière pays Lima
en est aussi la victime du haut des
collines dévale de curieuse termitières
humaines petit cube fait de treillis
recouverts ce sont les bariadas chaque
mois des familles d'Indiens descendants
de la montagne augmentent la population
de cette ville parasite qui s'accroche à
Lima phénomène propre à toutes les
grandes capitales du monde cette
migration prend ici un caractère
intensif et la capitale péruvienne qui
pourtant construit vite et beaucoup ne
peut absorber ce spectaculaire
accroissement de population
71 espagnols et 200 indiens autant de
pizzas 95
000 habitants 1850 Lima compte
aujourd'hui 2 millions d'armes
[Musique]
on conçoit qu'en période électorale les
courants politiques puissent trouver ici
de multiples raisonnables
l'armée a gardé l'habitude
hérité de 142 ans d'indépendance
d'arbitrer les situations devenues
délicates au Palais du gouvernement ou
veille des gardes républicains à la
France il est ainsi assez courant de
voir s'installer une jante militaire ce
fut le cas en juillet dernier et cette
jante vient d'obtenir la démission de
son chef le général Perez Godoy suspect
de vouloir s'opposer aux élections
prévues pour le mois de juin
dans la vie de Lima les élections sont
toujours l'occasion d'une grande
agitation de rue des cortèges
impressionnants se forment autour des
noms des candidats la présidente et tous
les 6 ans les limonias apportent là la
même passion que celle qu'il manifeste à
la corrida ou au match de football
[Musique]